wir reden heute über die präposition in
die bedeutung von im deutschen ist
ähnlich zu innen im englischen aber im
deutschen kann man ihn auch in
situationen nutzen wo man im englischen
zu oder ab sagt hier ist ein beispiel
ich gehe in das geschäft
ich bin in dem geschäft ich bin in der
uni ich bin in der schule aber ich bin
bei der arbeit
ich bin in berlin wird immer mit einem
artikel verwendet ich gehe in das haus
ich bin in dem haus ich bin im haus kann
man mit nazis und mit akkusativ
verwenden
abhängig von dem fall verändert sich
auch die deklination des artikels ich
gehe in den hof akkusativ ich stehe in
dem hof dativ den dativ verwendet man um
eine position oder lage zu beschreiben
den akkusativ verwendet man um eine
bewegung zu einem ort zu beschreiben
fakultativ ich gehe in das haus da tief
ich bin in dem haus ich bin im haus
akkusativ ich dir in die wohnung
datis ich bin in der wohnung wenn man
ihn mit dativ maskulin also mit dem
verwendet wird in zu ihm indem ich bin
in dem zimmer
ich bin im zimmer ich bin im flur in dem
flur
ich bin im treppenhaus in dem
treppenhaus wenn man ihn mit dem artikel
dass verwendet wird in das zu ins ich
gehe ins badezimmer in das badezimmer
da ist ein brief im briefkasten von
einem nur werbung ich tue ihm in den
müll
janosch meist müll in die mülltonne
jannis schmeißt die zigarettenkippe in
den aschenbecher janus geht in die
apotheke im schaffen
ich schalte das mikrofon in der hand
losgeht in dem supermarkt